Good morning John.
A warning: This video contains realities that
are sometimes unpleasant to confront!
Specifically, the reality of the mortality
of humans.
If that does not sound like the kind of thing
you want to hear about today, move along...there
is nothing to see here.
If, on the other hand, nerds singing too quickly
about the inevitability of your personal demise
and indeed universal oblivion sounds like
your cup of tea...Proceed.
Well, every living organism at one time was
dust
An assemblage of atoms from our atmosphere
and crust
These bits they come together, but only for
a time
From that very first self-replicator oozing
from the slime
We exist and then we don't, that's just how
we do
And...
Everyone you know someday will also be dead
too
We're all gonna die
It's the one sure thing on which every living
thing can rely
We're all gonna die
Everyone so far has died too
There's not a thing that you can do
And you and me and us we're all gonna dieeeeeeee!
Well, many folks will hope that there's a
way out of this song
That if we think real hard and act real tough
somehow we'll get along
We'll fix those telomeres, digitize our brains
Freeze our dying bodies 'till the remedy's
attained
Well, I have some bad news for you, you can't
outrun the hearse,
The explosion of the sun or heat death of
the universe
We're all gonna die
It's the one sure thing on which every living
thing can rely
We're all gonna die
The singularity won't save you
There's not a thing that you can do
And you and me and us we're all gonna dieeeeeeeee!
I forgot the last verse...um...
The marvelous truth of it all is that death
is such a gift
Because the only reason we can die is that
we even live
The improbability of life and you and me and
us
That we exist at all to sniff and kiss and
taste and hear and touch
We've used our minds to make so many awesome
things somehow
Including all of the words in the song you're
listening to right now
WE'RE ALL GONNA DIE
We're all gonna die
It's the one sure thing on which every living
thing can rely
We're all gonna die
It's the one thing you can't live through
There's not a thing that you can do
And you and me and us we're all gonna die-ie-ie-ie-ie-ie-iee.
So have a good time.
And be nice to each other.
Yeah.
Weird song topic.
Though not that weird if you listen to Dear
Hank and John.
I like to kinda understand my place in the
universe, and understanding that it is a brief
place.
That's not really how places work...
But you get what I mean, it's important to
me.
And now I find myself with some extra time,
so what's going on in my life?
Making a lot of SciShows, making some CrashCourses-just
started shooting our new CrashCourse series,
CrashCourse Philosophy, which won't be uploaded
for quite a while yet, so I apologize for
teasing.
I haven't seen Star Wars yet, I don't know
what kind of nerd I think I am.
And we just recorded our twenty-ninth podcast.
I cannot believe that we have been Dear Hank
and Johning for twenty-nine weeks!
And it was a real good one.
It'll be out on Monday...ah, or Tuesday.
We're not great with the schedule.
Ah!
I just had an idea!
Uh, so I just gave you some bad news.
The good news, though, there's lots of it.
Scheduled flights between the U.S. and Cuba
are going to resume for the first time in
fifty years!
The world just had its first year in which
the global economy grew while global carbon
emissions did not!
And, uh, women just voted for the first time
in Saudi Arabia.
And also some of them were voted into elected
positions!
I know that it seems like maybe that shouldn't
have just happened now, but at least it happened!
So yeah, some bad news, some good news, it
all balances out, everything's gonna be fine,
right?
Good?
I hope?
John, I will see you on Tuesday.